bonjour à tous et bienvenue à Bruxelles
émission spéciale aujourd'hui d'Europe
et d'autres puisque nous accueillons
Michel Barnier bonjour et merci d'être
avec nous sur le plateau d'Europe Hebdo
alors vous êtes en charge d'un
portefeuille très important commissaire
en charge du marché intérieur et des
services et Michel Barnier vous avez
reçu avec les 26 autres commissaires
européens François Hollande qui est venu
devant la Commission européenne ici à
Bruxelles ça se passe très rarement la
dernière fois c'était en 1997 avec
Jacques Chirac est-ce que François
Hollande qui est venu parler de la
politique française est-ce qu'il a été
convaincant
oui d'abord c'est rare que le Président
de la République Vienne le dernier
c'était Jacques Chirac le Premier
ministre français était venu François
Fillon et puis c'est pas rare pour les
autres dirigeants européens Madame
Merkel est venu participer à un déjeuner
de travail et d'autres chefs d'État moi
je trouve ça très normal
la commission Bruxelles c'est pas un
État étranger nous sommes là au service
de l'Union européenne des États membres
des autres institutions et donc c'est
très important que le français vient de
dialoguer ça a été extrêmement direct
comme il savait entre très sincère
c'était un examen c'était un on a parlé
d'un grand oral c'était pas du tout
l'été l'état d'esprit de cette réunion
c'était un dialogue entre le plein de
République qui vient expliquer sa
politique qui dit sa foi et son son
espoir pour l'Europe également son souci
de modifier et je peux comprendre ça
parce que moi-même je suis revenu à
Bruxelles il y a trois ans pour que l'on
retrouve une ligne qu'on avait abandonné
que celle de l'économie sociale de
marché plutôt que de se laisser mener
par cette idéologie ultralibérale qui
DOM dans le monde et en Europe depuis 30
ans donc le présent public a eu un
dialogue extrêmement clair et on n'a pas
eu de ce contrat puisqu'il s'agit d'un
contrat
de cette assainissement budgétaire que
la France doit faire pour elle-même et
c'est pas Bruxelles et c'est pas Berlin
c'est pas l'Europe c'est parce qu'on a
trop de dettes trop de déficits on va
pas continuer éternellement à dépenser
plus d'argent pour notre dette que pour
l'éducation de nos enfants donc quel est
le contrat justement
en échange de contrepartie a besoin pour
atteindre les 3% de déficit encore une
fois pour elle-même pour faire moins de
déficit moins dette ne pas pénaliser les
générations futures j'ai d'ailleurs
rappelé auprès de la République dans mon
intervention tout à l'heure que
Pierre Mendès France avait recommandé de
ne jamais sacrifier l'avenir au présent
et ce matin nous sommes tous devant
cette obligation de ne plus sacrifier
l'avenir les générations futures à notre
confort ou à notre situation
d'aujourd'hui est-ce que Paris a entendu
ce Président
nous nous la France s'est engagée dans
un programme de réforme certains
éléments sont déjà là notamment ce qu'on
appelle la Flexi sécurité du marché du
travail mais la nouvelle réforme des
retraites la réforme de l'apprentissage
voilà des réformes qui sont très
importantes encore une fois pour la
France pour elle-même et c'est pas les
autres qui vont venir faire ces réformes
pour les Français c'est les Français qui
doivent lui faire pour eux-mêmes et je
reviens ma première question en fait il
y a un doute ici à Bruxelles sur je
dirais sur la capacité de la France à se
réformer on a un peu le sentiment depuis
quelques mois ou depuis même quelques
années que la France pourrait devenir
assez rapidement le maillon faible de
l'Europe or c'est la deuxième économie
européenne donc évidemment c'est un
impact est-ce que ce qu'il a dit
François Hollande est-ce que ça a été de
nature rassuré les commissaires
européens dont vous êtes s'il y a un
doute il est pas d'aujourd'hui donc on
sait bien que la France est un pays très
centralisé
qui ne pratique pas le dialogue social
vous faites pas de réformes sans
dialogue social comme on les Allemands
font comment les les pays du nord de
l'Europe font c'est parce qu'ils ont
l'habitude de dialoguer branches par
branche entreprise par entreprise avec
des syndicats qui sont respectés qui
sont forts et donc en France il faut
qu'on prenne cette habitude de dialogue
social faute de quoi on ne pourra pas
réformer
je pense que la République a été
extrêmement clair et volontariste dans
ces engagements de poursuivre et
d'amplifier le problème de réforme pour
la France est-ce que vous pensez Michel
Barnier que deux ans c'est suffisant
pour engager ce changement de cap parce
que c'est quand même de réforme
importante dont il s'agit est-ce que la
France est capable de faire ce que ce
qu'on fait les Allemands par exemple une
question de volonté j'ai une question de
courage politique à la fois pour le
gouvernement qui va peut-être prendre
des mesures qui ne sont pas populaires
dans son électorat et puis j'ajoute pour
l'opposition qui devrait avoir le
courage politique de soutenir ces
réformes si elles vont dans le sens que
que nous souhaitons bon courage
politique de tous les côtés mais mais
deux ans oui c'est suffisant
ce Schroder a pas besoin de deux ans
pour décider d'un programme François
Fillon quand il a fait que Monsieur
Sarkozy la première réforme des
retraites qui n'est pas suffisante il
faut la compléter on l'a fait en moins
de 2 ans Michel Sapin le ministre
français du travail a fait une réforme
en moins de de six mois sur le marché du
travail donc c'est possible c'est une
question de volonté et de courage
politique donc pour vous les réformes
structurelles prioritaires à mener pour
la France
c'est d'abord les retraites le marché du
travail
elles sont en réalité contenues dans un
document que je crois très important qui
est le rapport de Louis Gallois rue
Gallois c'est pas Bruxelles ni Berlin
qui lui a demandé de faire ce rapport
c'est le gouvernement actuel c'est
François Hollande et il a tout dit
toutes les faiblesses françaises celle
de la France et notamment la difficulté
qu'on les entreprises à avoir des marges
à se développer parce qu'ils sont
écrasées par le le poids des charges il
faut alléger le le poids de ces charges
sur les entreprises notamment les
petites et bonnes entreprises il faut
réformer l'apprentissage regardons ce
que font les Allemands pour que la
formation correspondent au travail
disponible il faut développer
l'entrepôtre social l'entrepreneuriat
régional
l'entrepreneuriat familial et peut-être
avec des outils comme ceux qu'on
entendrait de créer des bandes publiques
et les banques régionales le soutenir
alors Michel Barny il se passe beaucoup
de choses en Europe en ce moment
notamment on va parler du dossier numéro
1 la lutte contre les paradis fiscaux
elle est lancée en Europe mais aussi
dans le monde clé de voûte de cette
bataille la fin programmée du secret
bancaire on en parle avec vous juste
après ce sujet signé Thibault Le Floch
les réunions se succèdent à Bruxelles
mais cette fois l'ordre du jour est
clair la lutte contre les paradis
fiscaux est devenu la priorité en Europe
il en va à la fois d'un impératif moral
c'est une nécessité exigée par l'opinion
publique et c'est aussi un problème de
finance publique un problème d'intérêt
économique chaque année dans l'Union
européenne 1000 milliards d'euros
échappent à l'impôt comment contrer la
fraude en généralisant l’échange
automatique d'information sur les
revenus et le capital au sein des États
membres c'est ce que propose la
Commission européenne objectif la fin du
secret bancaire dans toute l'Union d'ici
à 2015 la bataille est mondiale réunit
près de Londres les ministres des
Finances des 7 pays les plus riches de
la planète ont affiché un front uni
contre l'évasion fiscale
nous sommes tous d'accord sur
l'importance d'une action collective
pour lutter contre l'évasion fiscale
une enquête internationale a été ouverte
les états -Unis le Royaume-Uni et
l'Australie ont annoncé avoir recueilli
des milliers de données informatiques
sur des comptes secrets des tenues dans
les trous noirs de la finance mondiale
la masse d'information dépasserait de
loin celle de Love short lix et ses 2
millions et demi de fichiers révélés par
un consortium de journalistes selon une
source américaine les îles Vierges
caïman et cooks seraient visés par
l'enquête c'est pour l'instant le seul
élément qui a filtré de ces documents
alors Michel Barnier sur reportage là
qu'on vient de voir on a le sentiment
qu'on aurait pu voir quasiment le même
il y a 20 ans on a l'impression que les
choses piétinent on sent bien une
volonté politique de faire avancer les
choses à l'impression que les choses
piétinent on voit des égoïsmes nationaux
il y a des pays comme l'Autriche ou
Luxembourg bon vous vous êtes
commissaire européen qu'est-ce que vous
dites à ces pays-là qui disent nous on
veut garder notre secret bancaire les
choses ont piétiné pour une raison très
précise qu'il faut expliquer c'est que
toutes ces questions de fiscalité elles
sont gérées à l'unanimité entre les miss
des finances donc un ministre peut
bloquer et empêcher le mouvement des 26
autres et c'est un peu ce qui s'est
passé jusqu'à maintenant sauf que ces
produits depuis quelques semaines un
événement important avec ses fuites
massives de listing de gens qui ont
utilisé l'optimisation fiscale qui ont
utilisé ces paradis fiscaux plus
l'affaire Cahuzac en France plus des
affaires propres à chaque pays comme
celle-ci qui ont créé un nouvel état
d'esprit et nous sommes là nous
commissions avec nos textes sur la table
et nous disons votez-les tous les textes
ont été présentés par mon collègue
monsieur semetat contre les paradis
fiscaux pour la transparence pour
l'échange de données et d'informations
entre les banques automatiques moi-même
j'ai présenté un texte contre le
blanchiment de l'argent contre l'argent
du crime et tous ces textes sont là il
suffit maintenant de les voter et ce que
je sens y compris sur le secret bancaire
c'est que tout le monde bouge parce
qu'il y a cette nouvelle ambiance et
puis aussi parce que la crise fait que
l'évasion fiscale est encore plus
insupportable encore plus scandaleuse
1000 milliards à dire votre reportage
1000 milliards vous savez que 1000
milliards d'euros c'est le budget de
l'Union européenne pour 7 ans c'est pour
ça que c'est pas acceptable il y a un
sommaire européen qui va en parler en
particulier la semaine prochaine ici à
Bruxelles vous pensez que les choses
vont vraiment bouger entre chef d'État
ce que je sens au niveau des ministres
et j'étais il y a quelques jours avec
les mises des finances ce qu'on sent au
niveau des chefs d'État c'est qu'il y a
ce nouvel état d'esprit ce volontarisme
tous les pays les États-Unis le
Royaume-Uni la France l'Allemagne porte
ce sujet je pense qu'il va progresser
comme rarement même si les choses ont
été engagées après la crise notamment je
le rappelle par Nicolas Sarkozy et
Madame Merkel et j'ai pris Obama je
pense qu'il y a un nouvel élan qui est
donné à cette lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale alors justement votre collègue
commissaire européen c'est méta a parlé
même d'un délai il a dit qu'en 2015 dans
moins de 2 ans il y aura l'objectif
c'est de ne plus avoir de secret
bancaire en Europe est-ce que c'est
réaliste comme objectif 2015 plus de
secret bancaire
courageux qui prend beaucoup
d'initiatives que je soutiens en matière
de fiscalité y compris d'harmonisation
fiscale sur des sujets qui intéressent
les entreprises par exemple
l'harmonisation des bases de l'impôt sur
les sociétés à l'intérieur du même
marché européen donc s'il dis cela c'est
que je pense que il a les éléments pour
le dire qu'il s'est réaliste c'est lui
qui je suis en train de volonté des
dirigeants mais nous sentons je sens
cette nouvelle volonté de mettre à bas
ces paradis fiscaux est-ce que vous
pensez que la Commission européenne peut
avoir un mandat entre guillemets pour
renégocier les accords passés avec
certains territoires or l'Union
européenne comme Monaco ou notamment la
Suisse c'est lui qui peut répondre à
cette question ce que je sens que c'est
que dans ce nouveau mouvement qui
s'engage les pays de l'Union européenne
qui pratiquent encore le secret bancaire
vont bouger ils bougent le Luxembourg a
déjà bougé et que ces pays qui sont en
Europe quelquefois en dehors de l'Union
vont être amenés à être dans ce
mouvement plutôt que en dehors de ce
mouvement donc vous y voyez une nouvelle
marche de l'économie mondiale et
notamment de la fin de pays vois une
nouvelle marque de cette moralisation
générale de cette mise en ordre de ces
nouvelles de quoi avons-nous souffert
depuis 20 ou 30 ans dans ce grand vent
ultra libéral qui a soufflé sur le monde
entier avec la mondialisation c'est
d'absence de règles plus de gouvernance
pas de supervision des banquiers qui se
sont crus tout permis ou plutôt à qui on
a tout permis des bonus insensés des
produits toxiques tout ça c'est fini je
rappelle que moi je suis chargé de
régulation financière que j'ai présenté
28 lois de régulation depuis trois ans
la plupart arrive à meurturer en ce
moment aucun marché financier aucun
produit financier aucun acteur financier
n'échappera une régulation publique
alors justement Michel Barnier nous
avons voulu interroger un trader que
nous avons rencontré pour savoir ce
qu'il pensait de toute ce mouvement de
d'encadrement toute cette réglementation
engagée pour lutter contre les dérives
de la finance nous avons eu du mal à le
rencontrer il a accepté de témoigner
mais à visage couvert écouter son
témoignage et on vous fera réagir juste
après
il tire le haut de la fiche comme
Michael Douglas alias Gordon dans le
film Wall Street manipulateur sans
scrupules motivé uniquement par l'appât
du gain le trader fait son cinéma
dans la réalité pourtant pas facile de
l'aborder Marc 35 ans a accepté de
témoigner il a travaillé pendant 10 ans
pour de grandes banques à Londres et à
Paris il parle à visage couvert
un fantasme sur le trader l'argent
facile les filles les voitures de luxe
la cocaïne bon tout ça c'est du folklore
trader c'est quelqu'un qui va arriver
tôt le matin il commence sa journée en
général vers 7h du matin qui va parce
qu'il faut qu'il se prépare parce qu'à
9h le marché ouvre donc il faut qu'ils
travaillent déjà préparé sa journée
travailler pour gagner beaucoup d'argent
beaucoup trop pour certains le Parlement
européen a mis le hola sur les bonus en
votant une loi qui empêche les traders
de recevoir une prime supérieure à leur
salaire
il y a des dix de façon de contourner ça
vous avez un exemple simple vous êtes un
trader
correct vous devez un serre de base de
50.000 euros et en moyenne vous touchez
150000 euros de de bonus bon parce qu'il
va se passer c'est si demain on limite à
100% de votre revenu de base et ben la
banque qu'elle a fait qu'elle va doubler
votre salaire à la fois c'est 50 à
100.000 euros de salaire de base et vous
n'aurez plus de 100000 € de bonus en
2009 les grandes ce monde réunis à
Londres ont promis de réguler la finance
en interdisant ou en limitant le recours
à certaines pratiques
de ruban c'est que quand votre invité à
un marché sinon à uniquement la France
ou même à l'Union européenne
c'est on pourra toujours le faire à
Singapour à Hong Kong ou à New York il
faut plutôt voir dans le cadre du G20
alors si effectivement en cas de G20 on
arrive à persuader les plus grands
centres financiers de faire ça pourquoi
pas agent de l'ombre le trader est avant
tout un opérateur de marché qui achète
et vend des produits pour le compte de
son employeur quand vous avez votre
assurance vie vous demandez un rendement
annuel il faut qu'il y a un trader
derrière qu'il fasse tourner la machine
et qui fasse générer des bénéfices pour
que votre assurance vie puisse avoir les
deux ou trois pour cent annuels de
rendement
ces dernières années des réformes ont
été lancées pour remettre les acteurs de
la finance au service de l'économie mais
les pratiques ont-elles vraiment changé
alors c'est terrible ce qui nous dit
trader en plus c'est votre dossier c'est
vous qui avez limité les bonus des
banquiers et des traders à un an de
salaire en fait ce qu'il dit c'est que
ça sert à rien bon comment vous comment
vous entendez ça d'abord je connais
beaucoup de gens qui se lèvent à 7h du
matin ou même parfois plutôt des
ouvriers des paysans qui ne gagnent pas
50 000 euros par et qui sont très très
loin de gagner ce que gagne certains
jeunes dans certaines places financières
ce que nous avons voulu encadrer c'est
pas pour pénaliser des banquiers qui
font leur boulot généralement d'ailleurs
correctement c'est de limiter la prise
de risque car dans cette crise
financière qui est venue des États-Unis
on a vu des banquiers être d'autant plus
payés par des bonus qu'il prenait plus
de risques
quand les risques mettaient leurs
banques en difficulté qu'est-ce qu'il
paye les risques sont les contribuables
ça suffit donc nous voulons interdire
cette prise de risque en tout cas la
maîtriser et moi je pense que la mesure
quand je vois à quel point elle a été
combattue à Londres par le Parlement
européen que j'ai soutenu je pense cette
mesure va produire des effets il nous
dit on va augmenter notre notre salaire
principal comme ça on va détourner oui
sauf que moi je vais présenter un autre
texte à la fin de cette année qui va
responsabiliser les actionnaires je veux
que pour un salon de rémunération les
plus élevés et d'une manière générale
les actionnaires soient responsabilisés
pour fixer eux-mêmes et prendre la
responsabilité des salaires qu'il paye
dans l'entreprise dont ils sont
actionnaires et qu'il y ait de la
transparence et on verra bien si au bout
de la route tous ces gens continuent à
vouloir détourner le sentiment que le
fait de payer beaucoup les traders ça va
leur permettre à eux de gagner beaucoup
en dividende est-ce que j'ai envie de
dire ils sont pas un peu du même bord
regardez le mouvement qui s'est engagé
qu'on appelait le printemps des
actionnaires on un peu partout y compris
dans la grande place financière
européenne qui est Londres à Paris à
Francfort des actionnaires qui veulent
prendre leur responsabilité qu'il
n'acceptent plus n'importe quoi qui
n'excède plus que ce soit des choses
soient décidées en dehors d'eux et donc
je pense que ce mouvement général
d'encadrement il est nécessaire encore
une fois non pas pour empêcher les
marchés financiers de fonctionner mais
pour les remettre au service de
l'économie réelle au service des
entreprises et des territoires plutôt
que d'être à leur propre service en
gagnant le maximum de profits dans le
minimum de temps alors justement
concrètement comment peut-on faire ça
parce qu'on a l'impression en écoutant
ce trader cette opérateur de marché que
le trader a toujours un train d'avance
sur les institutions comment est-ce que
Bruxelles peut faire pour remettre tout
le monde au pas pour remettre ces
acteurs là au service de l'économie
d'abord ces gens sont obligés de
respecter les lois européennes qui vont
s'appliquer ou qui s'applique déjà les
règles sur la capitalisation des banques
sur la limitation des bonus sur les
ratios de liquidité les règles sur la
transparence
concernant les produits dérivés
à partir de maintenant les produits
dérivés que qu'utilisent ces gens qui
d'ailleurs n'aiment pas beaucoup la
lumière mais nous sommes en train de
mettre de la lumière sur chacun d'entre
eux ce sont 600000 milliards écoutez-moi
bien 600000 milliards de dollars de
transactions qui étaient pour 80 %
d'entre elles sous la table over de
compteur c'est-à-dire degrés à gré nous
allons obliger nous obligeons maintenant
les Américains font la même chose un
enregistrement de cette transaction donc
partout la règle ça va être transparence
responsabilité
régulation et finalement remettre de la
morale si je puis dire là où elle avait
disparu et quand il dit bon ok on va pas
le faire à Londres ni à Paris parce que
ça sera interdit par l'Europe mais du
coup ça va se faire Hong Kong
ces gens là ne font pas beaucoup de
philanthropie vous venez de le rappeler
néanmoins le marché européen reste le
principal marché du monde
500 millions de consommateurs 22
millions d'entreprises donc c'est un
marché s'ils veulent être là ils sont
obligés d'être là s'ils veulent
l'utiliser ils sont obligés de venir
chez nous et donc il reste plus ton
règle et puis parallèlement nous
travaillons au niveau du G20 pour que
ces règles européennes nous ont parfois
un peu d'avance nous les façons
parallèlement avec les Américains avec
les Chinois avec les Brésiliens avec les
Indiens c'est un engagement mondial
celui du G20 de remettre de l'ordre dans
la finance alors une question aussi
peut-être sur une autre avancée
européenne importante l'Union bancaire
vous y avez beaucoup travaillé j'ai
travaillé également elle se met en place
progressivement une question très
concrète pour le citoyen qui nous
regarde le nom bancaire c'est quoi
est-ce que c'est la garantie que c'est
dépôts seront assurés demain en cas de
de nouvelles crises bancaires une chose
qui est claire c'est que les dépôts en
dessous de 100.000 euros sont partout
n'importe où durablement préserver et
protéger c'est le cas aujourd'hui il y a
une directive européenne en cas de
faillite parce qu'on a vu que pour
Chypre c'était pas tout à fait clair
ou le 4 faillite était là la loi
européenne s'applique même s'il y a eu
un problème de communication j'ai été
qu'on puisse garantir à Chypre comme par
tout ailleurs les dépôts en dessous de
100000 euros mais l'union bancaire c'est
bien autre chose que ça c'est la
supervision des 6000 banques européennes
par la Banque centrale européenne dans
la zone euro c'est-à-dire même manuel de
régulation et de supervision les mêmes
règles qui s'appliquent partout ça c'est
aussi une leçon que nous tirons de la
crise que les banques soient bien
supervisées parce que ça a été une crise
de la supervision cette crise financière
et puis nous ajoutons ce qu'on appelle
la résolution c'est à dire pour chacune
des grandes banques l'obligation de
préparer le cas échant une faillite pour
que la faillite soit ordonnée plutôt que
de laisser arriver dans la crise des
faillites deux ordonnées qu'on demande
de contribuables de payer moi je ne veux
plus que les contribuables payent pour
les banque payent pour les banques on a
vu que certains en Europe je crois que
c'est le cas des Allemands disent ok
100000 euros c'est bien mais en fait
c'est pas suffisant il faudrait
carrément que l'ensemble des dépôts
bancaires quel que soit la somme soit
garantie est-ce que c'est possible
d'abord est-ce que ça peut fonctionner
actuellement au-delà de 100000 €, les
dépôts bancaires ne sont pas garantis en
cas de faillite il peut se passer
n'importe quoi d'ailleurs on a utilisé
des dépôts au dessus de 100 000 à Chypre
ce que je veux que moi c'est que les
choses soient annoncées transparentes
clairement affichées et que
actionnaires créancier déposant d'une
banque sache s'agissant de cette banque
à laquelle ils font confiance ce à quoi
ils peuvent s'attendre s'il y a des
difficultés je suis aussi favorable à la
préférence des déposants c'est à dire
que les dépôts bancaires même au-dessus
de 100 000 soit les derniers appelés en
cas de faillite et donc c'est ce que
nous discutons avec les mises et
finances actuellement alors Michel
Barnier la Commission européenne que
vous représentez est chargée aussi de
veiller au bon fonctionnement du marché
européen certaines pratiques qui ont
pourtant cours l'Allemagne fait
notamment appel à des ouvriers venus des
pays de l'Est qui travaillent dans des
conditions très difficiles vous allez le
voir avec ce zapping des télévisions
européennes
a perdu son travail il y a trois mois
depuis il n'a reçu aucune indemnité son
employeur une entreprise qui fabrique de
la soupe ne répond pas à ses courriers
ce n'est pas un cas isolé des Roumains
des Polonais des Hongrois connaissent le
même sort et 60% des personnels de
l'industrie de la viande viennent des
pays d'Europe centrale et orientale ils
viennent chercher le travail qu'il ne
trouve pas chez eux
interdiction de filmer dans l'abattoir
mais aux abords du citron le voile les
travailleurs sont surtout roumains et
bulgares ici il travaille 60 heures par
semaine de jours comme de nuit pour
trois à quatre euros de l'heure
les deux tiers des salariés ici viennent
de l'Est Roumanie Pologne Hongrie
Bulgarie ils sont payés en moyenne 700
euros par mois trois fois moins que les
Allemands en effet si l'entreprise
emploie directement un salarié elle le
paiera en moyenne 15 euros de l'heure
dont 5 de charges soit 10 euros pour le
salarié or elle fait appel à des
sous-traitants moins chers 10 euros de
l'heure ceci emploie alors tour des
salariés déduisent à leur tour charge
des marges au bout du compte
l'intérimaire est payé au mieux 4 euros
de l'heure
la nouvelle que l'Allemagne ouvre
largement ses portes au travailleur
roumain s'est vite répandus dans le pays
pour 8 heures de travail un découpeur de
viande qualifié peut gagner plus de 1000
euros par mois
on n'a pas le choix on est obligé
d'aller voir à l'étranger mais ceux qui
se pressent pour déposer leur CV doivent
savoir que le travail est très difficile
puisqu'il faut être capable de découper
à Port en 15 minutes chrono
à cet ensemble de reportages est-ce
qu'il est normal de voir de telles
pratiques au sein de l'Union européenne
et notamment dans la première économie
européenne je réagis en ayant une
conviction que j'ai depuis longtemps
avec laquelle je suis revenu à la
commission c'est qu'il faut que l'Europe
sociale progresse qu'il y ait une union
sociale un jour crédible qui accompagne
l'union monétaire l'union économique
l'Union bancaire ou financière et donc
clairement il faudra qu'il y ait dans
chaque pays pas forcément au même niveau
un salaire minimum qui est assez alumium
dans chaque branche déjà il y a des
progrès qui ont été faits sur les
conditions de travail la sécurité au
travail mais on voit bien aussi qu'il y
a des pratiques qui ne sont pas normal
d'ailleurs nous enquêtons sur certaines
d'entre elles
ma conclusion ma réflexion c'est qu'il
faut faire progresser l'Europe sociale
en même temps que en instaurant par
exemple un salaire minimum parce que
l'Allemagne dit qu'elle est dans la
légalité puisqu'il n'y a pas de salaire
minimum la Commission a changé de
position depuis deux ou trois ans c'est
aussi un progrès auquel j'ai contribué
pour demander qu'il y ait dans chaque
pays à salaire minimum encore une fois
ça peut pas être le même salaire minimum
en Allemagne et en Roumanie mais au
moins un salaire minimum et puis des
salaires minimum aussi par branche voilà
voilà le progrès que nous souhaitons et
auquel nous croyons avec les ministres
est-ce que c'est cette absence de
d'Europe sociale qui a votre avis
explique pour l'instant ce désamour des
Européens particulièrement des Français
d'ailleurs ce qui a eu un sondage récent
qui montre que la confiance dans
l'Europe telle qu'elle est en train de
se bâtir est en train de tomber de façon
très importante qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez quand vous voyez que les Français
finalement aujourd'hui ils aiment pas ce
que Bruxelles et donc la Commission
européenne leur propose
c'est sans doute l'absence ou
l'insuffisance de l'Europe sociale c'est
aussi plus généralement la crise ou les
crises comme jamais on en a affronté qui
crée tant de chômage de difficultés pour
les jeunes de colère ou de difficultés
sociales donc les probablement ça qui
créent un climat dans lequel la chambre
d'homme politique ou d'acteurs de
l'économie trouve commode de dire c'est
la faute de Bruxelles encore une fois
c'est pas Bruxelles ni Berlin qui a
obligé la France à ne pas avoir de
budget en équilibre depuis 37 ans c'est
pas à Bruxelles ou Berlin qui explique
la France est une dette équivalente à
94% de son PIB c'est-à-dire la richesse
d'une année voilà la dette des Français
qui fait qu'on paye plus pour notre
dette que pour l'éducation de nos
enfants ça c'est pas les autres c'est
nous donc il faut je pense qu'il y a des
choses à corriger à Bruxelles moi je
pense qu'il faut changer l'Europe je
suis revenu pour participer à ce
changement et nous vous le voyez bien
concrètement nous le faisons la
régulation financière
les professions que j'ai évoquées sur le
plan social ce que je fais sur
l'entrepreneuriat social nous nous
progressons la ligne bouge tout
doucement mais mais ça ne suffit pas en
revanche il faut aussi que dans chaque
pays on assume ses responsabilités et je
pense aussi qu'il faut expliquer
pourquoi on a besoin d'être ensemble
plutôt que chacun chez soi pourquoi il
faut être européen en même temps que
d'être patriote parce que dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui face ou à côté de la Chine
des États-Unis du Brésil de l'Inde de la
Russie si nous ne sommes pas ensemble
nous sommes out nous sommes hors de
l'écran nous sommes sous-traitants nous
sommes sous influence des autres et moi
j'ai pas envie que mon pays soit sous
influence et sous-traitant et c'est sans
doute une raison d'espérer à donner pour
le citoyen européen qui doute merci
beaucoup merci